moyenne mamane bonjour bonjour à l'iss
ben je vous remercie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
je vous remercie également c'est un
plaisir pour moi alors vous êtes
sociologue
oui vous enseigner à l'université hassan
ii de casablanca oui alors depuis
quelques jours vous êtes au québec
oui pourquoi êtes vous là je suis là
parce que j'aime beaucoup le québec
je suis là aussi parce que mes filles
ont fait leurs études ici même à
montréal
j'ai beaucoup d'amis je suis très
intéressé par tout ce qui se passe au
niveau des lois de niveau du féminisme
niveau de la société civile
j'ai beaucoup d'amis ici et il y a pour
moi une dynamique culturelle qui est
très importante et que je suis j'essaye
de suivre régulièrement ce qui me
dérange c'est la neige et le froid qui
dure trop longtemps chez vous oh mais
c'est une condition qui violence tout le
monde vous manqués arrive par l'est qui
tombent sous la pluie de neige cette
tempête de neige mais vous arrivez à un
très très bon moment soleil commence à
pointer à l'horizon
c'est vrai ça devient agréable c'est
super alors vous êtes donc odeurs
autriche où auteurs session d'erreurs
oui voilà
auteur très prolifique
vous avez écrit pas mal d'ouvragés
généralement quand je lis vos titres ça
me suggère quelque chose votre dimension
très féministes nous les femmes vous les
hommes
oui c'est pas juste c'est le dernier je
dénonce ce qui me semble être des
injustices dans mon pays ou ailleurs je
dénonce pour informer sensibiliser
essayer de faire en sorte que les lois
changent aussi pour protéger les
personnes qui sont défavorisés par la
société par des individus et par des
institutions ou par des manquements de
loi et en tant que féministe vous devez
dénoncer des injustices qui concerne
généralement les femmes beaucoup oui oui
puisque ce sont les femmes qui se trouve
aujourd'hui dans une situation plus ou
moins avilie si normal si demain il y
avait des hommes qui se trouvaient dans
cette situation je ne serai pas
féministe je serai masculinistes je sais
pas si ça existe faudrait l'inventer
mais il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui
vers le monde ce sont surtout les femmes
qui souffrent d'inéquité d'inégalité et
d'injustice
justement parlant d' injustice est-ce
qu'on peut les nommer particulièrement
au manque au maroc est ce que ce serait
seulement maroc est ce que ce serait on
à gré parce que ce serait seulement dans
les pays musulmans est ce que ce serait
à travers le monde parce que les
injustices perdure elle vis-à-vis des
femmes à travers le monde
au maroc ce qui me semble être
aujourd'hui important c'est qu'il y ait
des lois qui protègent les femmes nous
avons eu une réforme du code de la
famille qu'on appelle la moudouwana en
2003-2004 van hamme grâce à la
mobilisation des féministes de la
société civile des intellectuels etc et
ce fut réellement une réforme qui était
vraiment révolutionnaire maintenant
entre 2004 et 2010 9 qui s'est passé
quand même près de deux décennies et il
ya encore des lois qui doivent être
modernisées moderniser actualisé parce
que le profil des femmes marocaines
change mule à une vitesse extraordinaire
et les lois parfois ne suivent pas alors
moi mon cheval de bataille en ce moment
ce serait l'une égalité successorale au
niveau de l'héritage basculement au tout
à fait comme dans la plupart des pays
d'afrique un d'afrique subsaharienne
aussi mais je viens généralement c'est
des endroits où les femmes sont spoliés
sous prétexte qu'elles n'ont pas droit à
l'héritage est ce que c'est toujours le
cas au maroc
oui c'est toujours le cas sauf que le
l'héritage de partage est régie par la
charia
et quand on dit la chaîne est assez
l'islam c'est le coran c'est l'ailé à la
tradition a dit la tradition prophétique
c'est l'exégèse de manière générale et
aujourd'hui quand on parle de réformer
le lay lay l'héritage on est face à des
je vais dire pas seulement des
intégristes des obscurantistes à des
conservateurs et conservatrice également
de façon générale parce qu'on va vous
dire tout de suite non c'est le coran or
on peut réformer dans l'islam il est le
tiède c'est à dire cette capacité que
l'exégèse réforme pour compte pour
contextualiser et c'est ce qu'on demande
et malheureusement aujourd'hui il y à
des barrières il ya des obstacles qui
font qu'on ne peut pas en parler de
façon sereine et tout de suite on vous
dit non
dans le coran mais le coran dans le
coran il ya une très grande ouverture et
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que par
rapport à l'héritage le coran quand il a
été révélé les femmes méritait pas du
tout or le coran a attribué à la femme
la moitié de la pâte de l'homme avec des
conditions puisque c'étaient les hommes
et toute la communauté qui prenait en
charge les femmes
aujourd'hui les femmes elles sont
pourvoyeurs elle-même pourvoyeuse de
famille un foyer sur six au maroc et
pour voiliers exclusivement par des
femmes les femmes travaillent pour leurs
familles pour leurs enfants elles
travaillent pour les pères pour les
frères pour les fils donc tout le
contexte a changé et les argument selon
lequel l'homme devait avoir plus pour
parce qu'ils entretenaient les femmes
aujourd'hui est brisé c'est un argument
brisé aujourd'hui pourtant avec
l'arrivée de mohamed 6 au pouvoir il ya
eu beaucoup d'espoir n'est ce pas
transporter par cette volonté de réforme
de modernisation de la société et qui
achoppe dans le nouveau code de la
famille justement par rapport à
l'héritage
le nouveau code de la famille 2004 n'a
pas parlé d'héritage puisqu'il y avait
d'autres priorités à gérer notamment au
niveau du mariage précoce mariages
précoces d'abord aux conditions du
divorce et ça oui exactement
puis le fait qu'une femme puisse se
marier sans avoir de tuteurs parce que
avant vous pouviez avoir 80 ans vous
voulez vous marier vous fallait un homme
ça pouvait être votre frère de le faire
vous avez toutes les chances qu'il soit
déjà parti
ça pouvait être votre fils c'est aussi
le fait que le mariage était sous la
domination de l'homme alors que là il ya
une égalité entre le mariage
il est sous la responsabilité pardon de
l'homme et de la femme mais l'héritage
n'était pas encore si vous voulez il
faisait pas partie des priorités
j'ai écrit le premier article qui a été
écrit au maroc sur cette inégalité
c'était en 1994 et il a suscité un très
grand scandale et après on ait
l'impression que l'on est passé vers
d'autres priorités qui ont donné cette
réforme de 2004 et là il ya cette prise
de conscience je continue à batailler
pour au moins que le débat que le débat
soit mis sur place
des associations sont en train de se
mobiliser
il ya tout un réseau d'associations qui
actuellement près par tout un plaidoyer
donc si vous voulez le sait déjà pas mal
que le tableau soit brisée alors
avant c'était le grand tabou alors vous
arrivez au québec dans un contexte tout
à fait particulier
il ya le gouvernement de la cac qui a
déposé un projet de loi le projet de loi
21 sur la laïcité de l'état et qui donc
interdit le port de signes religieux au
personnel de l'état en position de
coercition et qu'il est temps également
aux enseignants notamment les
enseignants du secteur public mais que
vous suggère ce projet écoutez moi je
suis vraiment très mitigé c'est quelque
chose qui me dérange le l'histoire du
port du voile opa a démarré en france il
ya quelques années et je trouve qu'on
attribuer trop d'importance à ce set ce
choix de porter ou par d'être voilées ou
pas je pense que on a on a accordé une
importance disproportionnée qui a fait
qu'on a eu des des réactions qui peuvent
se radicaliser et là j'arrive donc au
québec et je me rends compte qu'il ya un
certain malaise et une petite fracture
au niveau des gens que je connais même y
compris avec ma propre fille et je
n'aime pas la façon dont le débat est
abordée savez quand on parle de signe
finalement on parle de quoi il faut pas
se cacher on parle pas d'écran parle pas
de la kippa en parc du voile là on va
pas non mais je vois c'est vraiment oui
w9 c'est quoi c'est le foulard c'est le
voile c'est la burqa excellent ira moi
je suis très mal à l'aise par rapport à
ça parce que je pense que une personne a
le droit de se couvrir ou de se
découvrir
c'est un choix personnel une personne a
le droit de porter une kippa ou pas une
croix ou autre c'est un choix ou un
ruban un turban c'est un choix personnel
maintenant ce qui me dérange c'est quand
il ya une idéologie qui est lié à ce
morceau de tissu un seul morceau dit
voilà c'est ça c'est ça qui peut
déranger
qu'est ce qui se cache est ce que
quelque chose se cache en arrière en
arrière ou pas je peux vous dire par
exemple qu'au maroc nous avons des
femmes qui portent le foulard et qui
sont dans les associations et plus
féministe qui sont des avant gardistes
et qui chaque jour bataille dans leur
vie au quotidien pour leur liberté
auprès du mari aux prises dans l'espace
public etc
mais là où ça devient dérangeant
quand morse cette étoffe va empiéter ma
propre liberté c'est la liberté la
liberté des autres et qu'on peut dire
que au maroc certaines femmes qui
portent ces morceaux de tissus comme
vous l'appelez est ce que on peut penser
que ces femmes leur véhicule une
certaine idéologique certains groupes
c'est à dire elles peuvent lui pas
toujours on n'a pas le temps de
s'étendre sur les parce que bon si vous
saviez quelles étaient les raisons qui
font que les femmes portent le foulard
ou autre vous serez vraiment étonné
parfois la femme le porte pour se
libérer de l'est dans l'espace public
la jeune fille ne porte pour que ses
parents lui fasse plus confiance mais
qu'elle puisse sortir et revenir bon
qu'elle saisit rebonds n'a pas le temps
de parler de toutes ces raisons qui font
qu'une femme va porter un foulard mais
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
parmi les femmes qui choisissent de se
voiler entre guillemets on va dire
certaines le font parce qu'elles ont des
convictions religieuses
voilà et elles le vivent très bien elle
le respecte la liberté des autres mais
d'autres peuvent effectivement être là
pour vous donner des leçons vous dire
bon c'est l'islam attention il faut
couvrir et c est ce qui me dérange
encore dans tout ça c'est que finalement
le discours qu'on peut entretenir ces
cas chez vous pour que les hommes
restent de bons croyants donc à chez
vous pour que les hommes ne nous désire
pas dans la rue autorise à s'éveiller
quand une jeune fille d'une femme dit
j'ai fait le choix je suis convaincu que
je pars chasteté ou pour d'autres
raisons
j'ai le plus grand respect pour ce choix
mais moi quand on me dit les hommes les
femmes doivent se cacher cacher leurs
atours pour ne pas séduire l'homme qui
lui risque d'être affaibli dans sa piété
là c'est quelque chose qui me dérange
parce que oui j'allais poser la question
de savoir est ce combat rock on a des
femmes qui se battent pour enlever le
voile
que pensez vous de leur combat est-ce
qu'on a des mouvements réels contre le
voile non ça n'existe pas mais c'est
vraiment éparses et éparpillé c'est des
prises de position ses des discussions
parce que c'est même dans nos propres
familles nous avons ça nous avons des
femmes qui choisissent de pain de porter
ce vol à des femmes qui se sont libérés
dans les années 60 elles ont porté la
mini jupe elle était en bikini sur les
plages etc et qui aujourd'hui font le
choix c'est leur choix le plus moi je
respecte vous voyez temps encore une
fois que ça ne touche pas tant qu'elle
me laisse moi
me comporter et faire mes propres choix
et il n'y a pas vraiment de mouvements
mais on sent effectivement qu'il y a que
ça bascule vous voyez que healy a7 au
niveau des féministes par exemple des
associations il ya cette discussion ce
discours comme quoi nous avons bataillé
nos grands mères ont bataillé par
exemple ma grand mère a porté le niqab
avec la djellaba elle a enlevé dans les
années 50
ma mère s'est habillé à l'occidentale
c'était vraiment une prise de position
une manière de se libérer des jours que
des traditions et on a parfois
l'impression que on va revenir des
quelques décennies en arrière et c'est
même le discours qu'on retrouve ici au
québec parmi même les canadiennes on va
les québécois est ce qu'ils vont vous
dire oui on a un vraiment bataillé pour
obtenir notre liberté la démocratie le
droit et c est cette étoffe nous va nous
faire revenir en arrière c'est pas bon
je comprends votre mère vous avez fait
le choix de vous vêtir à l'occidentale
ego quoi tu as un suivisme ou simplement
pas une émancipation et je vais vous
dire la femme marocaine la plus moderne
et je pense que je suis assez moderne va
avoir dans sa garde-robe la djellaba le
caftan et on est capable d'avoir les
deux c'est à dire que la bon pour moi
c'est quelque chose de pratique pour
marcher pour pour travail etc
j'ai fait le choix de ce qui était
pratique parce que c'est vraiment le
pantalon est plus pratique que la
djellaba le costume marocain
traditionnel est connu à travers le
monde pour être un costume d'une extrême
beauté les plus grands stylistes y
compris saint laurent se sont inspirés
de du costume traditionnel marocain
on le porte très souvent chez nous à la
maison quand on reçoit pour être à
l'aise dans les mariages donc nous
moi j'ai moins comme les femmes comme
moi ont le plus grand respect pour ce
cet habit traditionnel on le porte
beaucoup pendant le mois de ramadan pour
être plus à l'aise le soir mais je pense
que on voit là nous avons cette liberté
de choisir la bille qui convient au
contexte dans lequel on se trouve c'est
très pratico pratique on va donc venir
là c'est la dernière question avocat cet
ouvrage vous dites les femmes dans le
maroc d'hier et d'aujourd'hui wind
parlant d' égalité oui
ou est-ce qu'on est rendu aujourd'hui
alors par rapport aux réalités en face à
l'égalité hommes femmes il faut savoir
que le maroc a ratifié toutes les
conventions internationales
là on est vraiment protéger vous avez
comparé tout à l'heure comme partout
ailleurs non comme pas comme partout
ailleurs dans les pays musulmans et
arabes le nom du nord sas et c'est une
orientation c'est elle c'est un choix
politique qui vient et de dieu du roi
dont vous avez parlé de médecine dont
vous n'avez pas que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure qui vient aussi d'une
politique d'état qui est aussi sous
l'impulsion de la société civile etc
donc voilà ça et la ratification
c'est un nous avons le code de la
famille qui est vraiment qui a été
révolutionnaire mais on demande
actuellement une autre réforme parce que
l'aide commence à être fond de la
réforme la réforme de la réforme oui et
jamais spontanément 93 je crois oui en
une autre en 2004 2004 et nous demeurons
c'est normal parce que le profil des
femmes change à une vitesse mais très
très très rapide
c'est tout à fait normal qu'une loi
aujourd'hui elle est adaptée et 5,6 duo
va durer une décennie plus tard elle
devient obsolète et c'est pour ça qu'on
demande une réactualisation parce que le
profil des femmes est en train de
changer de la société et des hameaux si
vous savez aujourd'hui par son talent
nous avons je vous donne un chiffre
parmi la population au maroc est âgé de
plus de 10 ans c'est pratiquement le
tiers de la population qui est
analphabète mais aujourd'hui pour les
moins de 10 ans est pratiquement 100%
des filles qui sont scolarisés et
comptant par lé défi on parle de 40%
d'un pays qui a 40 % de ruraux et quand
on se rend compte que dans au niveau du
rural où il ya le plus de conservatisme
vous avez sans pratiquement 100% de
petites filles qui sont scolarisés
ça veut dire que il ya des
transformations au niveau des mentalités
des femmes mais aussi des hommes parce
que le père qui envoie sa fille à
l'école et donc le maroc change à une
vitesse très très rapide et c'est tout à
fait normal que nous demandant des
réformes et nous allons lui demander
toute une vie parce qu'il faut savoir
que le maroc en termes d
solution par rapport à la société par
rapport à la condition de la femme
rapport aux mentalités et c'est
finalement nous avons commencé cette
marche libyen à partir pratiquement des
années 60
ça fait pas longtemps ça fait soixante
haut à peu près et ont 60 ans nous avons
réalisé ce que par exemple les
québécoises ont réalisé pratiquement en
un siècle la fête maintenant je
comprends maintenant et c'est pour ça
que les réformes doivent être plus
rapide
tout à fait mais la toute toute dernière
je vous ai entendu dire c'est le père
qui envoie sa fille à l'école oui ça
veut dire la société reste très très
patriarcale non ce n'est pas ce que je
voulais dire s'il devait y avoir un
obstacle nous l'aimons nerveux
scolariser leurs enfants
mais avant les filles n'étaient pas
scolarisés pour moi parce que l'honneur
des familles repose sur les filles le
chirac et qui sait que quelques équipes
qui sont les gardiens de l'honneur chez
les hommes c'est le vert qui pouvait
refuser d'envoyer la fille à l'école en
six ans il faut la mariée vite parce
qu'elle risque d'avoir des rapports
sexuels et aidera donc l'obstacle
s'était pas les mères l'obstacle c'était
le père et signifie sont scolarisés ça
veut dire aujourd'hui que il n'y a plus
du tout cet obstacle que les verts
veulent et parmi eux mêmes les 40% de
ruraux veulent donner des chances de
réussite à leur fille et accepte de les
laisser occuper un espace hors du
cloître dans lequel les femmes étaient
et le mariage précoce alors le mariage
et donc est à 18 ans le mariage précoce
continue à s'exercer dans dépendant des
taux de moins en moins important il
continue mais ce qui est important c'est
que il continue à s'exercer mais à tout
un mouvement qui revendique vraiment il
ya tout un mouvement associatif des
intellectuels etc qui revendique le fait
que l'on arrête cette enfin ce n'est pas
un fléau je vais vraiment en voilà une
injustice je dirais voilà c'était donc
soumaya naâmane guessous vous êtes donc
professeur d'université orizet
l'université hassan ii de casablanca
très intéressante avec pas mal de
publication sur le féminisme les femmes
l'émancipation voilà c'est ça voilà on a
pas mal de titres concernant les femmes
mais aussi les hommes mais aussi les
ennemis d'allah
parfait donc elle est là vous pouvez
l'entendre c'est dans deux ou trois
jours à l'université
demain je serai à l'uqam un migrant à
12h30
voilà et après demain je serai à lui dm
tout à fait excellent conférencière je
vous remercie beaucoup d'être venu nous
voir
je vous remercie également pour
l'accueil merci